[Música]
periodistas nicaragüenses pidieron la
inmediata liberación del reportero
Víctor ticai quien fue detenido el
jueves tras cubrir una procesión
católica en el municipio de andaime la
organización movimiento periodistas y
comunicadores independientes aseguró que
es una medida represiva y de
criminalización de la labor periodística
México continuó la repatriación de los
cuerpos de los migrantes que fallecieron
en medio del incendio en un centro de
detención de Ciudad Juárez registrado el
pasado 27 de marzo siete cuerpos de
salvadoreños Fueron trasladados por
tierra hacia su país
en Estados Unidos quedó en vilo el uso
de la píldora abortiva tras las
decisiones contrarias de dos jueces en
el estado de Texas un juez prohibió su
uso en todo el país al considerarla un
medicamento no seguro a su vez un juez
de Washington ordenó proteger su acceso
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Nicaragua donde el movimiento
periodistas y comunicadores
independientes pidió la liberación del
reportero Víctor ticai detenido el
jueves tras cubrir una procesión
religiosa en el municipio de andaime la
asociación asegura que el periodista fue
detenido sin ninguna justificación por
lo que calificó la medida de represiva y
criminalizadora de la labor periodística
la detención de tikai se produce un día
después de que transmitiera una
actividad religiosa que la policía
intentó evitar
estamos viendo tanto asedio que hay
contra la parroquia diferentes
han prohibido las acusaciones de la
procesiones pero el fervor del pueblo no
lo van a vencer nuestra iglesia el
reporte que tenga
totalmente llena en el sábado continuó
la repatriación de los restos de los
migrantes que fallecieron en medio del
incendio registrado el pasado 27 de
marzo en un centro de detención de
migrantes de Ciudad Juárez el viernes
fue repatriado el primer cuerpo de un
ciudadano colombiano que llegó a Bogotá
y el sábado salieron por carretera los
restos de siete salvadoreños trasladados
a su país en los actos de Semana Santa
Los feligreses pidieron acciones para
castigar a los responsables
Pues de que tomen conciencia y ya de ver
el acto que vieron aquí del los
migrantes que pues Lamentablemente se
fallecieron entonces que tomen cartas en
el asunto para que no vuelva a suceder
la misma acción y el acto que sucedió
ellos dijeron queremos hacer un vía
crucis viviente y terminarlo donde
murieron nuestros hermanos nosotros solo
acompañamos su sed de Dios solo
acompañamos su inquietud de de ser
testimonio de oración para
sociedad en Estados Unidos un juez
Federal de Texas suspendió el uso de una
popular píldora abortiva momentos
después desde Washington otro juez
emitió una sentencia contradictoria
instando a que se mantuviera el acceso
al fármaco en al menos 20 estados el
gobierno de Joe biden afirmó que luchará
por mantener el derecho de las mujeres a
acceder a la píldora veamos
el acceso a una popular píldora abortiva
está ahora en entredicho después de que
dos jueces federales emitieran
sentencias opuestas sobre su uso hace
más de dos décadas que la administración
de alimentos y medicamentos aprobó la
misma prehistona sin embargo en
respuesta a una demanda interpuesta por
antiabortistas que cuestionaban la
seguridad de la píldora un juez
conservador de Texas prohibió su uso
Escala Nacional casi al tiempo en otro
caso un juez de Washington nombrado por
Obama dictó una sentencia contraria
ordenando que el medicamento siguiera
disponible en 17 estados
las afectadas por no tener acceso a
estas píldoras seguras y legales son
personas de bajo ingresos es muy
probable que sean de zonas Rurales y
generalmente personas afroamericanas por
tanto tendrá un impacto enorme en
aquellas mujeres que ya están marginadas
socialmente
el gobierno vaiden afirma que luchará
por preservar el acceso al aborto
farmacológico seguro
diré que no hay duda de que presidente y
yo apoyamos a las mujeres de Estados
Unidos y haremos todo lo posible para
garantizar que las mujeres tengan la
capacidad de tomar decisiones sobre su
salud reproductiva de la manera que
ellas lo necesitan y eso lo deciden
ellas no su gobierno
la demanda de píldoras abortivas en
Estados Unidos aumentó drásticamente
después de que la Corte Suprema anulara
el año pasado Robert versus White
poniendo fin al derecho constitucional
al aborto el departamento de Justicia
dijo que impugnará la sentencia de Texas
que los grupos de defensa de derecho
reproductivos han calificado de ataques
sin precedentes contra la misión de la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos las dos resoluciones
judiciales implican que el asunto
llegará con toda probabilidad al
tribunal supremo de Estados Unidos entre
tanto en Colombia las autoridades
geológicas informaron que la actividad
del volcán nevado del Ruiz sigue siendo
muy inestable Y decidieron mantener la
alerta naranja las autoridades
resaltaron que el viernes se registraron
3.400 sismos y solo en la mañana del
sábado hubo alrededor de 800 el servicio
geológico destacó que la sismicidad
relacionada con el movimiento de fluidos
al interior de los conductos volcánicos
estuvo asociada a varias emisiones
bursátiles y continuas de ceniza
los sismos están localizando entre dos y
cuatro kilómetros del cráter un poquito
más cerca pero en general en ese mismo
Rango y a dos de dos a cuatro kilómetros
de profundidad respecto a la cima del
cráter
continúa la emisión de cenizas ha sido
más continuo durante estos días y la
cual se dispersa de acuerdo a la
dirección de los vientos por otra parte
persiste las anomalías térmicas
el 8 de abril se cumplieron 10 años de
la exhumación del poeta chileno Pablo
Neruda con el fin de investigar la
verdadera causa de su muerte en esta
década no se ha dictado una sentencia
firme si bien es un último informe
pericial publicado este mismo año
asegura que Neruda fue envenenado con la
bacteria del botulismo tal y como
denunció en una querella el partido
comunista de chile recordemos que el
poeta murió tan solo 12 días después del
golpe de estado de Augusto pinochet
contra el gobierno de Salvador Allende
el informe es de la agencia F
diez años después de empezar a buscar la
causa de la muerte de Pablo Neruda su
cuerpo Descansa en el mismo lugar en
donde lo exhumaron en 2013 en ese año
los restos del poeta chileno y Premio
Nobel de literatura enterrado en la que
fue su residencia en el municipio de
isla negra en la costa de chile fueron
trasladados bajo una estricta vigilancia
y supervisión médica hasta los
laboratorios forenses encargados de
esclarecer las causas de su muerte
sin embargo tras una década las
incógnitas sobre su fallecimiento que
ocurrió 12 días después del golpe
militar de Augusto pinochet en 1973
Siguen sin resolver los primeros
análisis forenses realizados en 2013 no
encontraron veneno entre los restos de
Pablo Neruda Aunque un informe posterior
de 2017 reveló la presencia de la
bacteria clostridium botulínica en una
muela que puede generar la enfermedad
del botulismo letal en personas si ahora
no se ha determinado oficialmente que el
poeta fuera envenenado la jueza que
lleva el caso Paula Plaza dispone de un
tercer informe forense que según ella
será el definitivo para saber las causas
de la muerte de Neruda según la familia
del poeta que conoce los detalles de la
causa este tercer informe desvelará que
la bacteria del clostridium no tendría
por qué haber estado en la osamenta de
Neruda el sobrino del poeta Rodolfo
Reyes en exclusiva F el pasado febrero
avanzó que los expertos del Tercer
informe forense concluyen que la
bacteria no se filtró al Cadáver de
Neruda desde dentro o alrededor de su
ataúd sino que ya lo tenía antes de
morir
miles de guatemaltecos participaron en
las tradicionales conmemoraciones y
actos católicos de la Semana Santa en
medio de túnicas indumentaria típica y
flores hicieron parte de las procesiones
y demás ritos que desde noviembre de
2022 fueron declarados patrimonio de la
UNESCO precisamente despedimos esta
emisión con las imágenes destacadas de
la celebraciones de la semana más
importante para el catolicismo en
América el continente con más feligreses
de esta religión
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi espíritu
[Música]
aceptamos
esta estación vamos a pedir
por todos nosotros
[Música]